dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly shown IFA
I have recently been witnessing a few
heated conversations regarding the
submission of deep learning papers to
computer vision conferences the forums
are up in arms about the fact that
despite some of these papers showcase
remarkably good results they were
rejected on the basis off from what I
have heard not adding too much to the
tree of knowledge they argue that we
don't understand what is going on in
these neural networks and cannot really
learn anything new from them
I try to understand and rephrase their
argument differently we know exactly how
to train a neural network it's just that
as an output of this process we get a
model of something that resembles a
brain as a collection of neurons and
circumstances under which these neurons
are activated we store these in a file
that can take up to several gigabytes
and the best solutions are often not
intuitively understandable for us for
instance in this video we are training a
neural network to classify these points
correctly but what exactly can we learn
if we look into these neurons now
imagine that in practice we don't have a
handful of these boxes but millions of
them and more complex than the ones you
see here let's start with a simple
example that hopefully helps getting a
better grip of this argument now I'll be
damned if this video won't be more than
a couple minutes so this is going to be
one of those slightly extended two
minute papers episodes I hope you don't
mind the grammatical rules of my native
language a lot of them are contained in
enormous tomes that everyone has to go
through during their school years rules
are important they give the scaffoldings
for constructing sentences that are
grammatically correct can we explain or
even enumerate these rules well unless
you are a linguist the answer is no
almost no one really remembers more than
a few rules but every native speaker
knows how their language should be
spoken and it is because we have heard a
lot of sentences that are correct and
learned it by heart what makes a proper
sentence and what is gibberish this is
exactly what neural networks do they are
trained in a very similar way in fact
they are so effective at it that if we
try to forcefully insert some of our
knowledge in there the solutions are
going to get worse it is therefore an
appropriate time to ask questions like
what merits a paper and what do we
define a scientific progress what if we
have extremely accurate algorithms where
we don't know what is going on under the
hood or simpler more intuitive
algorithms that may be subpar in
accuracy if we have a top-tier
scientific conference where only a very
limited number of papers get accepted
which ones shall we accept I hope that
this question will spark a productive
discussion and hopefully scientific
research venues will be more vigilant
about this question in the future okay
so the question is crystal clear
knowledge or efficiency how about
possible solutions can we extract
scientific insights out of these neural
networks model compression is a way to
essentially compress the information in
this brainish thing this collection of
neurons we described earlier to
demonstrate why this is such a cool idea
let's quickly jump to this program by
deepmind that plays atari games at an
amazingly high level in break out the
solution program that you see here is
essentially an enormous table that
describes what the program should do
when it sees different inputs it is so
enormous that it has many millions of
records in there a manual of many
thousand pages if you will it is easy to
execute for a computer but completely
impossible for us to understand why and
how it works however if we intuitively
think about the game itself we could
actually write a super simple program in
one line of code that would almost be as
good as this all we need to do is try to
follow the ball with the paddle one line
of code and pretty decent results not
optimal but quite decent from such a
program we can actually learn something
about the game essentially what we could
do with these enormous tables is
compressing them into much much smaller
ones ones that are so tiny that we can
actually
build an intuition from them this way
the output of a machine learning
technique wouldn't only be an extremely
efficient program but finally the output
of the procedure would be knowledge
insight if you think about it such an
algorithm would essentially do research
by itself at first it would randomly try
experimenting and after a large amount
of observations are collected these
observations would be explained by a
small number of rules that is exactly
the definition of research and perhaps
this is one of the more interesting
future frontiers of machine learning
research and by the way earlier we have
talked about a fantastic paper on neural
programmer interpreters that also aim to
output complete algorithms that can be
directly used and understood the link is
available in the description box thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time
you